Wow this is a huge huge crap well thank
you all for having me thank you for your
time
I'm going to do something a little bit
different something I've never really
done before which is simply read to you
from some books that have helped me
along the way help me along a transition
help me get started but also help me
through many things and there's so many
lessons in these books and and please if
you get a chance buy them yourselves and
read through the entire things but I'm
going to give you some highlights and
some of my experience with the passages
the first book is a book called the art
spirit by Robert Henry who was a painter
and I know there's a lot of affinity for
painters in these parts this is about
creativity through the lens of an art
student and I'm going to read it through
my phone because I could not find a book
store that would sell me a paperback
version of this today so we're going to
bring up iBooks it starts off art when
really understood is a province of every
human being it is simply a question of
doing things anything well it is not an
outside extra thing when the artist is
alive in any person whatever his kind of
work may be he becomes an inventive
searching daring self-expressing
creature he becomes interesting to other
people he disturbs upsets enlightens and
he opens ways for better understanding
were those who are not artists are
trying to close the book he opens it he
shows they're still more pages possible
and I think that's so telling for
everything that you all are about to do
all the challenges you're about to face
you're going to be the ones that open
the book the world would stagnate
without him and the world would be
beautiful with him for he is interesting
to himself and he is interesting to
others he does not have to be a painter
or a sculptor to be an artist he can
work in any medium he simply has to find
the gain in the work itself
not outside of it one of the biggest
lessons that I've learned throughout my
career is how important the work is how
important not just the end product is
but the actual craft doing the work
inventing within the work the work of
the art student is no light matter few
have the courage and stamina to see it
through you have to make up your mind to
be alone in many ways we like sympathy
as humans and we like to be in company
it is easier than going it alone but
alone one gints gets acquainted with
himself grows up and on not stopping
with the crowd it cost to do this if you
succeed someone you may have to pay for
it as well as enjoy it for the rest of
your life and that's something if you do
something meaningful you are going to
have to pay for it in all the work but
at the same time you will also be able
to enjoy it for the rest of your life we
are not here to do what has already been
done everyone in this room feels that we
are not here to do what has already been
done know what the old masters did know
how they compose their pictures but do
not fall into the conventions they
established these conventions were right
for them and they are wonderful they
made their language you make yours they
can help you all the past can help you I
think in Silicon Valley and especially
in technology it's so easy to fall in
the footsteps of others to do what they
do because you think it's the right
because the right way because you think
you've they've had the success and you
can copy that success you have to find
your own path you have to find your own
footsteps
an art student must be a master from the
beginning that is he must be the master
of such as he has by being now master of
such as he has there's promise that he
will be a master in the future and what
I mean what he means by this is purely
you have to be a master of your own
tools that mastership is not is not a
destination it is a process and it's
constant practice that
there it is not enough to have thought
great things before doing the work we
have so many ideas but what really
matters is the work to implement those
ideas no don't worry about the
rejections everybody everybody that
that's good has gone through it don't
let it matter if your works are not
accepted at once the better or more
personal you are the less likely they
are of acceptance just remember that the
object of painting pictures is not
simply to get them in exhibition it is
all very fine to have your pictures hung
but you are painting for yourself not
for the jury and what's meaningful about
this passage to me is we work so hard to
get some sort of acceptance in the world
to get some sort of positive feedback
and we look at others and it seemed so
fast their success it seems like they
did it in just a moment but it takes
years and years and years and patience
but marking interface is not easy in
this there's a time and place for all
things the difficulty is to use them
only in their proper time and place
there's a time and place for all things
the difficulty is to use them only in
the proper time in place with motive you
will become clairvoyant of means you
will cease and command them without
motive you will wobble about this in
building a team and building an
organization building a company is one
of the greatest lessons you cannot do
anything without a shared and common
sense of purpose if you don't have
motive if you don't have purpose that
are shared between everyone you will
wander about you will wobble and you
will not do anything of infinite means
you will not do anything that is
timeless and lastly
student of these days is a pioneer just
like all of you the are student of today
must pioneer beyond the mere matters of
fact I believe the great artists of the
future will use fewer words copy fewer
things essays will be shorter in words
and longer in meaning I love this
passage I believe the great artists of
the future will use fewer words copy
fewer things essays will be shorter in
words and longer in meaning we must
paint only what is important to us must
not respond to outside demands they do
not know what they want or what we have
to give I think one of the most
important things about what you all of
you do is that you are building what you
want to see in the world you're making
that bet that other people want to see
the same thing in the world sometimes
you lose a bet sometimes you win the bet
but the most important thing is you have
that passion to build for yourself
because that is what's infectious and
that is what brings other people to your
cause and to your team the second book
is by a local favorite his name is Bill
Walsh who was the coach of the 49ers of
San Francisco 49ers
he took a team that was at the very very
bottom and he brought them to the top he
focused entirely on the details he
didn't come in and just say you all need
to win games he said you need to tuck in
your shirts you need to clean your
lockers this is how we answer the phones
here he set a new standard of
performance
one of the hardest transitions anyone
has to make and especially anyone in
this room has to make is going from
individual creation to actually leading
a team it's something that I certainly
fumbled with along the way I was not
really excited about reading any
leadership books or management books and
this was actually the first one that I
ever read and it was given to me by
Keith rude boy when I hired him as our
GM of square and on 23rd employee I want
to read a few passages of it from from
this book to you so he starts off the
book by saying running a football
franchise is not unlike renting any
other business you start first with a
structural format and basic philosophy
and then find people who can implement
it you start first with an idea and a
philosophy of purpose a mission and then
you go and you find people to help you
implement it the book if you read it and
I definitely encourage you to read this
book if you're thinking about leading
teams are building a company or leading
a team within an organization is a
series of lists series of lists of what
to do in a series of lists of what not
to do
and he starts off by establishing a
standard of performance and Bill's
standard of performances us first when
you establish the standard performance
with your team you start with a
comprehensive recognition of reverence
for an identification of the specific
actions and attitudes relevant to your
team's performance and production number
two you'd be clear and clear and
communicating your expectation of high
effort and execution of your standard
performance number three let all know
that you expect them to possess the
highest level of expertise in their area
and responsibility number four
beyond standards and methodology you
teach your beliefs your values and your
philosophy
number five teach connection and
extension you don't want a group of
independent contractors you want people
who feel connected that can actually
expand the organization and number six
make the expectations and metrics of
competence the demand in action and
attitudes from personal the new reality
year of your organization now what's
important about this is as you start
building a team you need to set
expectations around how people need to
perform in the company how people need
to act in the company and these can be
very very simple things but without that
you are rudderless you will react to the
outside and if you react to the outside
you are building someone else's roadmap
and you're building someone else's dream
instead of your own and as you grow your
collective own
bill goes on to write about being a
leader 12 habit 12 habits of what to be
in a leader and Bill has a lot of again
what to do what not to do and this is
the best example of that number one be
yourself number two be committed to
excellence number three be positive
which is probably one of the hardest
things to do as you start building a
technology or as you start building a
company number four be prepared
good luck is a product of good planning
it's not so much that people are lucky
is that they're prepared to recognize
fortunate situations and act on them
immediately when they occur number five
beat detail-oriented in Bill's way he
came into an organization that lost
every single season that had no chance
of getting to the Super Bowl and he
talked about those small details that no
one pays attention to push in our chairs
tuck in our shirts act professional
because if you build an organization
that does that you build an organization
that cares about itself and cares about
doing great and setting its own standard
of performance and constantly raising
the bar on that number six be organized
number seven be accountable number eight
be our Neve near-sighted and far-sighted
near-sighted is very very easy for us to
do farsighted
is not so much number nine be fair
number ten be firm number eleven be
flexible number twelve believe in
yourself and the next show number
thirteen be a leader what that means and
what that means is actually getting up
there and showing and not telling and
then he got talks about what not to do
exhibit patience paralyzing patience
number one number two engage in
delegating massive delegating are
conversely engage in too little
delegating number three act in a tedious
overly cautious manner
number four become best buddies with
certain employees
playing favoritism number five spend
excessive amounts of time socializing
with superiors or subordinates number
six failed to continue hard-nosed
performance evaluations of long time or
tenured staff members the ones most
likely to go on cruise control or to
relax and this I see in so many startups
is the folks that start early have the
least pressure in the company when they
should actually have the most pressure
in the company number seven fail to
actively participate in efforts to
praise and acquire new hires number
eight trust others to carry out your
fundamental duties fundamental duties
number nine find ways to get out from
under the responsibilities of your
position to move accountability from you
yourself to others
and the blame game and number ten
promote an organizational environment
that is comfortable and laid-back in the
miss belief that the workplace should be
fun light-hearted and free from
appropriate levels of tension and
urgency and you want both you want to
contrast between fun and also having a
good amount of tension one of the things
that he references his General Patton
and General Patton's List during World
War one he had five six points which was
how General Patton ran his army number
one remember that praise is more
valuable than blame number two use every
means before and after comment to tell
troops what they're going to do and what
they have done this goes back to setting
expectations and making sure everything
everyone knows what's expected them and
what to prepare for number three
discipline is based on pride in the
profession of arms on meticulous
attention to details and on mutual
respect and confidence number four
officers must assert themselves by
example and by voice number five general
officers must be seen in the front line
during action again show don't Oh number
six there's a tendency for the chain of
command to overload junior officers by
excessive requirements in the way of
training
and reports and finally as you continue
to build as you succeed there develops
what bill walsh calls a disease which is
the success disease what happens when
you really start winning what happens to
an organization when you start winning
when what happens when you start having
minor wins that turn into major wins he
wanted to protect against this as well
so he created yet another list number
one formally celebrate and observe the
momentous achievement the victory and
make sure that everyone feels ownership
of it
number two allow Pat's on the back for a
limited time number three be
apprehensive about applause number four
develop a plan for your staff that gets
him back into the mode of operation that
produce success in the first place
and number five addressed specific
situations that need shoring up focus on
the mistakes that were made and things
that were not up to snuff in the success
number six be demanding do not relax
number seven don't fall prey to
overconfidence so that you can feel you
can chant you can or should make change
for the sake of change number eight use
the time immediately following success
as an opportunity to make hard decisions
this one stuck with me the most
there is never a better time to do the
hard things when things are going
extremely well and that can be as an
individual that can be as a team as well
number nine never fall prey to the
belief that getting to the top makes
everything easy it doesn't it makes it
harder and number ten recognize that
mastery is a process not a destination
so that's what Bill Walsh had to say the
book is the score takes care of itself a
fantastic fantastic tome of lists and
everything that he's learned in managing
some very very hard and ego-driven
people football players through a the
most losing of this team in the world
- winning four Super Bowls in a row
amazing amazing turnaround that he did
by building a team and focusing on those
details bill inspired me to create a
number of lists of my own and I wanted
to share a tool that I use on a daily
basis that has been most fundamental in
my own growth and my own establishment
of practices so this is participatory
I'd ask you to bring out your phone
right now or your computer and bring
something out that you're going to view
on a daily basis on my dock on my iPhone
I have notes and notes of something that
I check every single day I have a note
for every single person that I encounter
in the company I have a note for every
single thing that I'm that I'm doing
every person that I talk with in the
company such as Sarah fryer or CFO at
square has one specific note in my
notepad and anytime I need to talk to
her about something I write it down and
then whenever I see her I go through my
entire list very very simple memory
device but what I want to talk to you
about today is a note which I call daily
so if you create a new note in your
notepad or something that you check on a
daily basis this is the most important
thing name it daily and then write the
word do colon and then go down a few
lines and write the word don't colon and
the one thing I would ask you to do
walking out of this is to every single
day just for a week wake up to this note
check it throughout the day and then
also before you fall asleep check to
make sure that you did and you didn't do
everything so what you put in each one
of these is you have a list of
everything that you want to do every
single day and you have a list of things
that you don't want to do and the
easiest way to add to the don'ts is to
notice something that you never want to
do it again you never want to do again
and you just add that to it very very
simple I'm just going to share some of
mine these might be a little bit
personal and embarrassing but here we
are
number one on my do list is to stay
present I think it's so easy to get
trapped in the past it's so easy to
think about the future the most
important thing is I stay present and
just reading this brings me back to the
present brings me back to this moment
number two for me is be vulnerable show
people my mistakes show people my fears
because they can relate because they're
going through similar things number
three
drink only lemon water and red wine
great we red wine is a great modifier
for it this goes with one of my don't
which is don't drink hard liquor or beer
on weekdays number three is six sets of
twenty squats and push-ups throughout
the day I just have to do them every day
six sets of 30-second planks run for
three miles
meditate on this list stand up straight
which whenever I say always C posture
moving in the audience say hello to
everyone
I just bought a heavy bag so I'm
training with a heavy bag so I want to
spend ten minutes with a heavy bag every
day I want to do a video journal every
single day and I want to get seven hours
of sleep on my don't list and again this
is one of the hardest things and a lot
of these are personal so I'm not going
to read all of them
well my don't list is don't avoid
eye-contact
don't be late don't set expectations for
someone and not meet them don't eat
sugar I'm on the Paleo diet so don't eat
wheat lentils or dairy and then of
course don't drink hard liquor beer all
the weekdays so this list while it
sounds very very simple has been
fundamental in establishing patterns for
myself and it's something that I do
check
every single morning I check throughout
the day and I check right before I go to
bed and I make sure that I check
everything off and go through it I've
given it to our companies I've given it
to a number of students that I've talked
to as we've gone to schools and
recruiting and people have come back to
me and said that this is something that
works for me it's something that's easy
to do in something easy to remember one
of the most fundamental things about it
that I've learned that I've taken away
from it is how it gives you focus how it
gives you something that allows you to
really ignore everything else that's
going on all the other noise to allow
you to focus on what's most important so
this doin don't list for people and
individuals in the company has
translated to a doin don't list for our
company for square we have a doin don't
list we have these are the things that
we're going to do these are the core
things these are our bold bets and these
are the things we're saying no to for
right now has been fundamental in
allowing us to move fast to continue to
innovate and to really push the
boundaries and continue invent in
question and and reset everything that
we think about the organization so
normally I talk about entrepreneurship
and I talk about founding a team and I
talk about design and product I didn't
wanna do any of that today I just wanted
to share some of the books that have
kept me going the books that I've
learned so much from read so much from
and I didn't want to leave on a on a
sour note of just giving you a list of
10 or 12 things from from a football
coach I wanted to share and listen with
you what we end up doing when everything
goes right when we move from creation
individual creation and we find
something that resonates with other
people and we organize a team to build
something together what's the end
product it's something that delights
people it's something that they want to
listen to again and again it's something
that they can't help but engage in they
can't help but tap their feet too so I
want to leave you with one of my
favorite songs
how many of you heard the song I
recognize it at all
no one okay this will be excellent
though um this is a very very simple but
lively song and I find myself listening
to it non-stop but what it what it
reminds me of is just how simple
creation can be but also how complex it
can be how how strong you have to be to
get to something this deep to get to
something this essential to get to
something that actually strikes a chord
with so many people and potentially
strikes a chord with everyone on the
planet that is why we're all here in
this room we want to build something we
want to create something that resonates
with every single person on the planet
music does that in a very easy way but
it's very very hard to get to it so I'd
like to play for you this play this for
you and just listen for a minute
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
sonna goes really well with red wine
great red wine so if you take away
anything from this day it's that you are
the future you are the ones that have
the ideas in your head you're the only
ones that can actually build it for
yourself and that is your task you are
building what you want to see in the
world you are making a bet
with the world that it resonates with
other people sometimes you're going to
win the bet sometimes you're going to
lose the bet you put that loss on the
shelf and you bring it back another day
but it's up to you to make that
interpretation to make that equation and
to paint what you want to see in the
world thank you very much for your time
for your time and great luck and all of
your work
thank you